Do you get really overwhelmed in meetings
trying to take notes but also pay attention at the same exact time?
Well, this is the plot note,
and this is your answer with voice to word functioning.
It attaches to the back of your phone
and it's got an AI voice recorder and chat GPT empowered,
so it will record every word that's being said,
even on a phone call and even in a live meeting.
You download an app, and this is the main screen.
It lets you pick between the transcript,
the summary, a mind map of the information,
and whatever meeting you were in.
Whether it's a meeting, a speech,
an important conversation on the phone.
Whatever it is,
the plot note will record it and take all the notes for you.
It's linked right here in the TikTok shop.